[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de face aux territoires sur
tv5monde en direct avec nos partenaires
de ouest france de nice matin de france
antilles la montagne est de 20 minutes
vous retrouvez cette émission également
en direct sur les sites internet de nos
partenaires co producteur aujourd'hui
m'ont invité et bien c'est le président
de la commission des affaires étrangères
de la défense des forces armées du sénat
bonjour christian cambon et merci avec
nous sur ce plateau ce matin vous êtes
également bien sûr sénateur du
val-de-marne et membres du parti les
républicains on va revenir videmment
également sur l'état des républicains
dans le paysage politique en fin
d'émission grave historique au quai
d'orsay c'est la deuxième je crois qui
est eu lieu dans l'histoire du ministère
des affaires étrangères gérald darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur était auditionné
hier à 17 heures à propos des incidents
au stade de france par le sénat et puis
la guerre en ukraine vous êtes également
je le rappelle d'ailleurs également en
charge du contrôle des services secrets
français des renseignements donc c'est
une commission très importante du sénat
on va aborder bien sûr tous ces thèmes
dans cette émission cette grève au quai
d'orsay donc c'est je le rappelle pour
les téléspectateurs qui ne savent pas un
décret qui a été publiée entre les deux
tours de l'élection présidentielle
nokia qui tend à supprimer en fait deux
corps diplomatique important du quai
d'orsay le corps diplomatique je le
rappelle en deux chiffres ses 1800
diplomates du quai et c'est treize mille
cinq cents agents donc elle concerne
beaucoup de monde vous avez pris
position vous pour la grève ce qui est
un peu inédit pour un président d'une
commission parlementaire et vous est
absolument contre cette réforme du quai
d'orsay
je suis absolument contre cette réforme
qui est une grave erreur et je vous
espérait que le président de la
république qui en inaugurant ce second
mandat a dit qu'il souhaitait un mandat
à l'ecoute et bien écoutera cet après
midi cette manifestation des diplomates
inédite vie tout à fait inédite je crois
que c'est la seconde fois depuis 1958 ce
qui est quand même un événement et
je la soutiens parce que elle est à la
fois stupide et est une grave erreur sur
la forme et sur le fond sur la forme
parce que c'est un décret qui a été
signé entre les deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle ce qui ne signe jamais de
très bons textes d'une manière générale
et sur le fond et non et sur la forme le
parlement n'a même pas été mis au
courant nous n'avons été saisi d'aucun
débat alors je sais qu'il relève
l'organisation de l'administration
relève du pouvoir réglementaire mais il
me semble que c'est une décision
tellement importante que la moindre des
choses utilité d'en aviser le parlement
pour qu'on puisse en discuter et sur le
fond on va en parler aussi dans cette
émission le font bien sûr et donc c'est
sur la forme c'est pour ça que la
commission des affaires étrangères s'est
saisie de ce sujet j'ai confié à deux de
mes collègues la tâche de rédiger un
rapport nous sommes actuellement en
train de faire des auditions qui sont
vraiment ils vont toutes dans le même
sens et donc le sénat donnera un avis
officiel sur ce question comment est ce
qu a pas une forme de modernité que vous
rejetez parlons des états unis
d'amérique un ambassadeur des états unis
dans les grandes capitales du monde peut
être banquier dans le privé venir dans
le public enfin au service du
gouvernement comme on dit aux états unis
d'administration et repartir dans le
privé est-ce que ça crée pas au fond une
fluidité un professionnalisme
intéressant dans dans la carrière
d'abord du diplomate et surtout dans la
représentation de son pays il faudrait
déjà dire un mot sur la manière dont les
diplomates américains exercent leurs
fonctions nager l'occasion non j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer deux des
ambassadeurs des états unis à paris on
voit bien que ceux qui portent le
message et les dossiers ce sont les
collaborateurs c'est souvent le ministre
conseiller l'ambassadeur mouldi il prend
du temps à connaître les dossiers quand
il la réserve que l'ambassade
l'ambassadeur américain vient
effectivement
et nommé à la suite d'une d'une élection
présidentielle généralement et disons
c'est quelqu'un qui est proche du
président élu qui parfois même voulait
très bas ça pour la france du tout du
tout parce que je crois que justement ce
qui caractérise le corps diplomatique
français c'est un statut qui lui permet
d'abord de rester une totale objectivité
et deuxièmement d'avoir des compétences
c'est un vrai métier d'être diplomate
c'est un vrai métier c'est pas
simplement aller prendre le thé avec des
petits fours c'est au contraire une
capacité de négociation par exemple moi
j'ai rencontré de très nombreux exemples
ceux qui rédigent les résolutions des
nations au conseil de sécurité des
nations unies c'est un vrai travail
alors on va y revenir avec armelle le
goff sur cette crise au quai d'orsay
tout à l'heure je reçois aujourd'hui en
face aux territoires question cambon
quel président de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées au sénat il est notre
invité dans un instant françois-xavier
le front ouest france sur ce plateau
[Musique]
françois-xavier lefranc bonjour vous
êtes le rédacteur en chef de ouest
france qui est le plus le plus grand
quotidien francophone du monde
d'ailleurs et on va parler avec vous de
la politique de défense de la france
avec les 50 bonjour monsieur cambon et
fédérant d'ukraine nous rappellent si on
était si on était en fait d'oublier que
les questions défense c'est important
alors en tant que président de la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense la première loi de
programmation militaire sur lesquelles
vous avez eu à plancher elle engage est
finalement de forte progression du
budget de la défense c'était un choix
des manuels macron mais on se dit qu'est
ce qui s'est passé avant qu'est ce qu'on
a fait avant mais ce qu on a été naïfs
est-ce qu'on a été inconscient est ce
qu'on a oublié que c'était une affaire
sérieuse ou est-ce que l'état du monde
pouvait nous endormir un petit peu au
point de deux d'oublier que
l'augmentation des budgets de défense
était peut-être nécessaire
avant c'était ce que l'on appelle
couramment l'état de paix puisque nous
sommes passés en l'espace de quelques
mois à l'état de guerre en tous les cas
dans la situation du monde l'état de
paix quelles conséquences la hutte moi
j'ai assez j'ai participé à la
précédente loi de programmation
militaire où effectivement le
raisonnement des dirigeants de droite et
de gauche de toute sensibilité consisté
à dire puisque ça fait plus de 70 ans
qu'on ne connaît pas la guerre on va pas
dépenser des milliards pour entasser par
exemple des munitions qui sont obligés
d'être changées au bout de 2 5 à 10 ans
et donc on va constituer un stock
résonna mais les faits concrets ça a été
de procéder à ce que un ancien chef
d'état major des armées a appelé
l'éreintement de nos forces armées c'est
dire qu'on était arrivé à une situation
par exemple près de 50% nos hélicoptères
ne peuvent pas décoller faute de pièces
de rechange faute de formation à la ruse
de ce pilote disponible à la russe je
laisse cette affirmation jeu mais je
pense effectivement qu'il ya quelque
chose d'assez semblables et il nous
manquait du matériel il nous manquait du
temps de formation et nous manquer nous
nous sommes on est passé de on avait mis
le char on en a 250 on part tout a été
divisé par deux par trois ou par 4 parce
qu'encore une fois on était dans un état
de paix et donc notre vigilance était
affaibli et on en paye maintenant le
prix en tous les cas on s'aperçoit des
manques qui sont très graves et qui
convient de corriger l'effort de la
france il est réel puisque entre 2019 et
2025 on va dépenser 295 milliards
absolument pour notre défense et à titre
de comparaison entre 2014 et 2018 ça
représente une augmentation de 23%
des dépenses est-ce que c'est suffisant
selon vous alors déjà c'est un véritable
effort et le sénat qui n'est pas
identifiée comme appartenant à la
majorité présidentielle a néanmoins
soutenu constamment cet effort que le
président de la république a lancé et
qui a été mis en oeuvre j'allais dire
avec beaucoup de régularité c'est à dire
que chaque année nous avons eu 1
milliard 700 millions de dépenses
supplémentaires possibles ce qui doit
nous conduire fin 2000 25 à 50 milliards
a souligné d'ailleurs tout à fait celui
donc ça s'éteint c'est un effort
absolument unis il concerne non
seulement les matériels mais aussi ce
qu'on appelle la mc ou la mise en
condition opérationnelle c'est-à-dire
l'entraînement des forces ils concernent
aussi la situation des hommes et leur
sécurisation
moi j'ai été très attentif à ce que nos
missions notamment au sahel permettent à
ces femmes et à ces hommes d'être en
sécurité
je me suis rendu à trois reprises jouer
et donc j'ai pu voir que et on le voit
du reste actuellement le lancement d'un
nouveau sous marin le suffrin de la
classe du barracuda qui est un
un des meilleurs sous marin au monde on
voit apparaître les nouveaux airbus
militarisé qui permet des transports de
troupes du transport hospitalier ou du
transport de carburant on voit dans
l'armée terre l'arrivée des premiers
engins légers blindée du programme
scorpion donc tout ceci montre que
concrètement les choses avancent
maintenant
la loi de programmation militaire
prévoyait démarche un peu plus haute à
partir de 2023 3 milliards par an donc
il va falloir s'y accrocher donc c'est
bien en avance et en même temps la
commission vous présidez avait dit
attention il ya le coût des opérations
extérieures il y a aussi le coût de la
vente des rafale quand la france vend 10
rafale à la grèce par exemple ce sont
des rafales qui sont en service dans
qu'elle rachète derrière dérape des
rafales récent et ça fait des surcoûts
que vous aviez je crois qu'ils feraient
à sept ou huit milliards tout à fait
donc est ce que est ce qu'on n'est pas
déjà au delà
alors on a eu effectivement un petit
problème au milieu de la loi de
programmation militaire il ya un an et
demi la loi prévoyait une actualisation
devant le parlement le gouvernement pour
des raisons qui lui sont propres n'a pas
accepté cette actualisation par le
parlement et nous avons fait un rapport
qui a identifié effectivement qu'il
manquait huit ou neuf une offre près de
9 milliards du reste de dépenses ça a
été contestée par les militaires enfin
par le non pas par les militaires du
reste n'est pas
le ministère mais on n'a pas eu la
preuve de nos erreurs jusqu'à présent et
nous considérons qu'il y a toujours une
différence entre les sommes qui ont été
prélevés qui ont été prévus et celles
qui ont été mises en oeuvre finalement
la vraie question c'est de savoir si à
terme les militaires français auront les
moyens des missions qu'on leur demande
d'accomplir dans un monde
particulièrement dur c'est tout le sujet
nous nous avons conscience du fait que
les militaires reçoivent de l'autorité
politique
des démissions qui sont très
difficilement quand je suis au sahel je
vois des garçons qui partent le matin
sans savoir si rentreront le soir c'est
ça la réalité on les expose nous avons
entre les forces de souveraineté et les
autres professionnels d'armes et de
professionnels il faut leur donner les
moyens et les moyens juste regarder à
sion christian cambon vous êtes dans
l'opposition vous êtes membre du parti
républicain une position responsable
récents ça est ce que vous êtes bien
informé est ce que ça marche en france
ça est-ce que vous réguler enfin vous
réguliers vous contrôlez en tant que
président de la commission au sénat des
forces armées est ce qu'on vous informe
bien vous savez constitutionnellement le
parlement en france n'est pas par
rapport à nos voisins
l'institution la mieux en prise avec la
réalité gouvernement c'est à dire non ça
veut dire qu'on pourrait faire beaucoup
mieux je prends un exemple tout simple
depuis le 25 février date de début des
hostilités
si j'excepte les auditions que moi même
j'ai programmé ou les grandes les
entretiens où les coups de fil les
rencontres que j'ai pu avoir avec des
chefs militaires je n'ai eu de la part
du gouvernement aucune information
institutionnelle n'ya alors on peut
imaginer que parce qu'il ya les
élections le parlement mais le sénat
n'est pas en élection donc le sénat peut
tout à fait se réunir donc moi je réunis
ma commission quasiment toutes les
semaines pour le donner à mes collègues
la possibilité d'exercice se contrôler
mais nous n'avons aucun mécanisme qui
nous permet de dire par exemple voilà
les armes qui ont été livré à l'ukraine
donc je lis dans la presse j'ai appris
par la presse moi président de la
commission de la défense qu'on a des
livres et des canons caesar je remercie
le président de la république de me
l'avoir dit
voila voila journal très très bien la
réforme est une occasion
revenir à la cour des comptes qui s'est
félicité effectivement qu'à la
programmation hiver soit respectée c'est
de la bonne gestion mais elle dit aussi
attention il y aura des choix très
douloureux à faire en matière de dépense
publique donc est ce que nous avons les
moyens
c'est un choix de notre défense c'est un
choix politique et le malheureusement
nous sortons d'une crise qu vide qui a
mis en exergue d'autres besoins
notamment sur les hôpitaux on va avoir
une discussion très prochaine imagine au
mois de juillet sur le pouvoir d'achat
donc le gouvernement est là pour faire
des choix et je vais me battre avec
l'ensemble de mes collègues pour faire
en sorte que les choix de défense ne
soit pas passé
en seconde priorité parce que nous nous
apercevons que nous vivons dans un monde
excessivement dangereux à trois heures
de paris c'est la guerre avec des
centaines de morts chaque jour et on ne
sait pas du reste au jour d'aujourd'hui
comment cette affaire se terminera
encore donc il est absolument nécessaire
que notre gouvernement et le sous
l'impulsion du président de la
république et sur ce thème je n'ai pas
de raison de ne pas lui faire confiance
puisqu'il a fait lui-même des
déclarations il a dit que c'est toi
serait appliquée et qu'on irait plus
loin alors le plus loin il va falloir
l'évoqué peut-être dans une nouvelle loi
de programmation militaire et le gard en
l'espace de cinq ans beaucoup de choses
ont changé l'opposition responsable ce
sera aussi d'expliquer aux français fort
avec la pédagogie il faut que les
français comprennent mais c'est bien
pour ça que je pense que le parlement
devrait être mieux concerné est plus
concerné par ces choix parce qu'un jour
l'opinion publique vous savez l échange
entre l'opinion publique et du jour au
lendemain souvenez vous la guerre du
vietnam dont on parlait tous les jours
les gens n'en n'était véritablement ne
supportait plus ce genre d'information
en permanence bon la guerre d'ukraine
qui tous les jours vous demandez des
images atroces il peut y avoir une
réaction de la population donc il faut
expliquer pourquoi la france a besoin
d'une défense fort au sein de l'europe
et pour nous-mêmes bien évidemment c'est
christian cambon le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées qui est
notre invité ce matin chaunu qui est
dessinateur et collaborateurs de ouest
france c'est la tradition de cette
émission
françois-xavier le franc jeu c'est bien
à une question à vous poser christian
cambon on écoute on regarde
bonjour
ce n'est pas un cadeau on l'a fait à la
reine d'angleterre pour son jubilé en
faisant porter le chapeau aux supporters
anglais suite au fiasco de la finale
entre le real de madrid et liverpool au
stade de france en effet des hordes de
voyous ont attaqué et pillé dire le
public aux abords du stade et on l'a
entendu le tube des quatre de liverpool
help
gérald darmanin aurait-il attraper la
variole du singe bon en attendant il y
en a qui jubilent c'est vladimir poutine
lui qui aurait dû organiser cette finale
à saint pétersbourg bon la question que
je pose n'a rien à voir avec le foot
ball comme fidel castro l'embargo sur le
pétrole et le gaz russe ne risque-t-il
pas de maintenir au pouvoir vladimir
poutine aussi longtemps qu est la reine
d'angleterre
je ne sais pas si poutine restera aussi
longtemps que la reine d'angleterre mais
je pense qu'il est là pour longtemps
parce que j'observe simplement que sa
popularité augmenter de 20% depuis le
prêt de 80 % il est à 80 % de popularité
en russie le nucléaire français poutine
il a d'ailleurs tenu des propos un peu
inquiétant sur le nucléaire on parlait
beaucoup de la notion de dissuasion
nucléaire et lui commençait à parler de
frappes préventives est-ce qu'on n'a pas
changé de monde est-ce qu'on n'est pas
rentré dans le monde extrêmement
dangereux quand on entend des dirigeants
politiques de ce niveau évoqué la
possibilité de frappes préventives
c'est évidemment ce qui caractérise la
dernière période nous connaissions
depuis déjà quelques quelques années le
fait que les états puissent ans mettait
en avant systématiquement leurs propres
intérêts et les c'est plutôt le
multilatéralisme de côté voiliers du
reste le le rôle des nations unies qui
est quand même une organisation qui a
joué un rôle très important par le passé
et on voit bien qu'ils sont dans
l'impossibilité d'apporter des solutions
alors le fait de de parler véritablement
d'évoquer la menace nucléaire alors bien
sûr ça peut être un jeu une sorte de
dialectique pour faire en sorte que les
opinions publiques face aux mouvements
mais il faut être très vigilant et nous
le sommes nous forces armées sont en
alerte maximale
ce n'est pas un secret de révéler que
trois sous-marins nucléaires ont été
on a été mis en alerte ce qui est plutôt
rare généralement c'est un kit home donc
vous voyez qu'on est très attentif à ces
menaces et pour l'instant on ne peut
rien exclure même si au jour
d'aujourd'hui les experts nous disent
que l'utilisation des armes nucléaires
entraînerait de telles conséquences que
poutine réfléchir a quand même à deux
fois la une de ouest france françois
dans la ville de west en salle est
consacrée à l'inflation à l'augmentation
notamment du coût du papier papier ça
sert à faire des journaux mais pas que
et le papier flambe le coût du papier
flanc et puis alors il y à aussi à la
une une belle analyse dominique moïsi
sur le chantage de poutine le chantage
au blé comment répondre au chantage de
poutine et selon dominique moïsi ça
passe d'abord par l'aide massive à
l'ukraine voilà ouest france co
producteur de cette émission et premier
quotidien francophone du monde merci
françois xavier lefrançois tu le
rédacteur en chef dans un instant nous
passons à la deuxième partie de cette
émission juste un mot sur le ministre
des armées puisque on l'appelle comme ça
le nouveau 1 sébastien lecornu il est de
votre ancienne famille politique
ça va faciliter les liens avec vous vous
le connaissiez je le connais bien je le
connais bien du reste s'il n'avait pas
été renouvelé au gouvernement il serait
redevenu sénateur membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères et la
développe flux d'information vers vous
sera mais voilà jojo j'ose croire que
les rapports seront les meilleurs et
jean je forme le même voeu pour madame
colonna avec laquelle je n'ai pas eu de
contacts toujours cas aujourd'hui
contact amicale
comme il est parti à kiev alors
profitez-en pour lui passer un message
mais non là catherine colonna nouvelle
ministre des affaires étrangères n'a pas
pris contact avec le président de la
commission pro russe de la défense a
rappelé que mon collègue de l'assemblée
nationale ça fait rire mais les armées
elles et elles partaient à kiev qui
était une priorité que lui avait donné
le président de la république donc voilà
christian cambon président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées notre
invité dans un instant armelle le goff
de 20 minutes sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour armelle le goff merci d'être
avec nous dans un instant nous allons
revenir sur cette crise au quai d'orsay
évidemment une des principales
informations de cette matinée denis
carot le directeur des rédactions du
groupe nice matin à une question à vous
poser depuis nice christian cambon
l'écoutent
colonel vient de succéder à jean yves le
drian au ministère des affaires
étrangères vous connaissez bien celle
qui a été ministre de jacques chirac
avant d'être plus récemment ambassadrice
de france en grande bretagne
catherine colonna au quai d'orsay est ce
que c'est un bon choix
c'est le choix du président de la
république c'est une grande
professionnelle elle a exercé de
nombreuses responsabilités pas
simplement à l' on a été à rome
précédemment elle était secrétaire
d'état aux affaires européennes bon je
pense que c'est un signal d'apaisement
qui étaient adressées aux diplomates à
la veille de la grève manifestement le
signal ne suffit peut être pas mais a
priori je n'ai aucune raison de mettre
en doute les compétences et la volonté
de catherine colonna non seulement de
conduire la politique des affaires
étrangères sous l'autorité du président
un but mais d'avoir avec le parlement la
relation que nous avions avec jean yves
le drian avec lequel nous avons fort
bien travaillé donc on va passer le
message ce matin pour qu'elle vous
contacte quand même la une de nice-matin
rapidement puisque vous êtes en duplex
de nice denis carot on la voit dans un
instant voilà c'est encore un féminicide
de famille de 34 ans qui a été tué hier
à nice c'est son fils qui a prévenu la
police et à une de nice-matin voilà
armelle le goff on parle on reparle de
cette grève des diplomates unique qui
n'est dit ok danse et je crois que c'est
la deuxième fois dans l'histoire du quai
oui effectivement c'est la deuxième fois
et on parlait du profil fin de catherine
colonna ce choix d'un d'une diplomate
nommé au ministère des affaires
étrangères est-ce que tout de même c'est
pas un signal qui était envoyé au corps
diplomatique
écoutez c'est un c'est un signal et je
veux le prendre comme tel pour l'instant
la ministre n'a fait aucune déclaration
à ma connaissance lors de sa prise de
fonction son message a été assez bref
donc on l'attend aux actes et moi j'ai
bien l'intention évidemment de lui dire
lorsque j'aurai ce contact que la
réforme est vraiment inopportune
singulièrement dans le temps que nous
connaissons
nous sommes en situation de conflits mme
de conflits au niveau de l'ukraine ou de
la diplomatie française doit être
particulièrement armé vigilant notre
situation est un peu bousculé en afrique
on le sait il ya des campagnes anti
françaises mais nous avons absolument
besoin de rassurer nos diplômes a encore
une fois moi je fais confiance à priori
à madame colonna n'a que quelques jours
de présence à elle de bien comprendre la
signification que peut avoir cette grève
car si véritablement le personnel
diplomatique le corps diplomatique
vis avec difficulté
l'imposition de force de cette réforme
je crois que c'est un handicap pour elle
et je pense qu'elle va certainement
réfléchir pour peut-être atténuer ouvrir
la discussion les syndicats ont demandé
des assises de la diplomatie je pense
qu'il faut aller jusque là car en plus
cette réforme succède à des compressions
de personnel des diminutions de crédit
que nous avons sans cesse dénoncée et
donc je parcours les consulats généraux
dit-on dans les consulats généraux et
même dans les ambassades ont supprimé ce
que chaque année on demande à des
ambassadeurs de supprimer ce qu'on
appelle des au tp des équivalents de
temps placé hier des emplois bon et on
leur demande toujours d' assurer les
mêmes missions mais on le voit aussi
dans les instituts français on le voit à
la ffe
l'organisation de l'enseignement du
français à l'étranger qui est un élément
très important de rayonnement et je
pense que ce n'est pas une bonne chose
pour la diplomatie française qui a
toujours été identifiés comme une des
meilleures du monde est-ce que c'est
toujours le cas parce que tout de même
genre yves le drian au moment de la
passation de pouvoir avec catherine
colonna a est revenu sur cette affaire
des sous marins australiens là par
exemple c'est une faillite quand même de
la diplomatie française puisque
trop corps diplomatique savait déjà que
les australiens allaient se retourner
sur ce contrat de la même façon en
ukraine on a vu que les services
américains ou les services anglais était
bien plus informés et bien mieux informé
que le quai d'orsay qu'est ce qui s'est
passé alors le la politique de
renseignement en france n'est pas
manager uniquement par le quai d'orsay
quai d'orsay c'est le volet diplomatique
est aussi le volet sans fondement d'un
format diane renseignements désarmé on
est comme une contrôleuse renseignements
dans votre commission vous savez
pourquoi il ne fonctionne pas on essaye
de savoir on essaye de l'avoir s'est
passé il ya des choses que je ne peux
malheureusement pas dire puisque je
siège à la d league mais alors vraiment
est resté plus globale bon je je je je
pense que c'est une compétition entre
les services comme en non j'en écris il
faudrait regarder et cas par cas les
choses je pense qu'en ce qui concerne
locus parce qu'après il ya eu le coup
d'état au mali qu'il n'avait pas non
plus été totalement identifié bon je
pense que là il ya eu peut-être parfois
un petit peu ce sentiment français qu'
on avait cette coopération avec les
australiens et que personne n'allait la
remettre en cause il y avait des signes
très sérieux il y avait ce monsieur
morrison qui entre-temps a été battu
pour la plus grande satisfaction de
monsieur le drian et qui avaient envoyé
quand même des signes si le ministre
australien des premiers ministres qui
vient d'être battu aux élections voilà
il ya mais je pense que du reste en
l'occurrence les australiens font un
très mauvais calcul car en fait ils vont
avoir que des sous marins américains
dont ils ne sont même pas capables
d'assurer l'entretien puisque ils ne
connaissent du nucléaire en australie
que ce qui convient de faire pour les
radio pulmonaire donc je ne pense pas
qu'ils vont pouvoir agir dans ce sens
dont qu'ils auront peut-être quelques
marins australiens qui seront engagés
sur les sous-marins américains mais
jamais les sous jamais l'amérique ne
transférera des technologies aussi
sensible que ça ils ont fait une fois
aux anglais en 1958 et depuis c'est
terminé donc voilà mauvais calcul mais
je pense que on aurait sans doute est
être peut-être plus attentifs moi je ne
jette la pierre à personne nous avons eu
un compte rendu assez précis de nos
services
la dgsn notamment qui nous a dit on a
cru jusqu'au bout dur comme fer que la
situation de la l'intensité de la
coopération franco australienne est ce
que les autres les ce que les
australiens pouvait en tirer était
supérieur à la ce volte face ce sont de
mauvais alliés les américains
sont des alliés ce sont des amis et ce
sont des alliés il ya différentes idées
ils défendent leurs intérêts toujours et
la diplomatie française les défenses
suffisamment la diplomatique française
doit les défendre mais pour ça il faut
qu'on lui donne les moyens emmanuel
macron concernant le quai d'orsay avait
parlé d' état profond et ça explique en
partie sa volonté de réforme de ce corps
diplomatique qu'est ce que vous pensez
de ça est-ce que c'est pas nécessaire
quand même de revenir sur le
fonctionnement de ce corps qui est quand
même très fermé qui a ses petits malins
dit on alors les fonctionnaires du coup
nous et danser se cooptent entre eux ça
arrange dans des situations de 2 voilà
de changement d'ambassadeur de consuls
généraux on sait ce que c'est vrai oui
on va on va éclairer ce sujet des
nominations à travers notre rapport mais
moi je veux revenir sur la nécessité
d'avoir un corps de gens très compétents
il ya là la pratique des langues qui
crée tout de suite des liens évidemment
quand vous êtes dans un pays étranger si
vous en parlait la langue c'est tout à
fait facile vous avez la capacité de
négocier c'est très important
regardez ce que nos diplomates français
ont fait au moment du coc vide ils ont
rapatrié avec des moyens extraordinaires
180 mille de nos français à l'étranger
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
phénoménal il négocie actuellement face
aux iraniens à vienne mais ça a une
capacité de négociation en
administrateur français peut avoir cette
capacité là elle faire si vous ne
connaissez pas ce métier si vous n'avez
pas l'expérience est ce que vous croyez
que 1
le sous-préfet de vendôme peut demain
être nommé ambassadeur à oulan bator et
réciproquement durée c'est ce que
l'ambassadeur de france à oulan bator
peut devenir sous préfet de bordeaux moi
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas à ce
scénario je crois que c'est un scénario
totalement théorique voilà la une de
20minutes par malo oui on revient sûr à
l'ukraine
après
je plusse plusieurs mois de conflits et
la difficulté du coût des populations
civiles qui se retrouve c'est le titre
de la une armelle le goff qui dirigeait
la rédaction de 20 minutes tout de suite
question encore manqué notre invitée à
le président de la commission des
affaires étrangères des forces armées et
de la défense du sénat est avec nous en
direct notre partenaire du groupe centre
france la montagne cette semaine c'est
pauline marek ce qui est journaliste à
la montagne justement depuis clermont
ferrand à une question à vous poser
toujours sur l'ukraine l'on regarde ça
bonjour christian cambon catherine
colonna ministre des affaires étrangères
a fait une visite très remarquée à kiev
lundi avant elle se sont boris johnson
anthony blinken justin trudeau ursula
von der leyen qui ont fait le
déplacement mais il y en a un qui manque
à l'appel c'est emmanuel macron qui est
pourtant pressé de toutes parts
volodymyr zelensky le président
ukrainien lui même l'a invité à
constater ce qu'il qualifie de génocide
emmanuel macron at il raison de ne pas
se montrer en ukraine oui non je pense
qu'il faut qu'ils y aillent en tant que
président du conseil européen je crois
que c'est cet âge je crois savoir que
ses programmés je ne sais pas quand et
sous quelle forme je pense que de toute
façon il faut véritablement qui est
qu'il ya c'est absolument nécessaire et
le président du sénat va y aller et je
l'accompagnerai sûrement vous parlé avec
emmanuel macron avec le président de la
république où je lui parle dans des
moments particuliers que sont les
voyages de
d'état car nous avons un entretien en
tête à tête n'ont pas véritablement mais
ça c'est vous savez c'est une conception
du parlement mais moi j'ai des rapports
à vème république c'était la même chose
oui oui
fall jeu oui je pense enfin je n'ai pas
d'expérience des temps passés mais en
tous les cas moi je suis toujours à la
disposition de lui-même de ses
collaborateurs parce que même si on est
dans l'opposition on est dans une
position véritablement très raisonnable
et je crois l'avoir eu appuyé y compris
ma commission du reste dans tous les
grands dossiers car il faut que la
france ne parle que d'une seule voix sur
ces grands sujets merci beaucoup armelle
le goff directrice des de la rédaction
de 20 minutes dans un instant des
maîtres korkmaz de tv5 monde sur ce
plateau
[Musique]
bonjour des maîtres vous êtes
journaliste à la rédaction de tv5monde
traiter de sujets internationaux dans un
instant avec notre invité christian
cambon président de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées du sénat qui est avec nous
tout de suite on va se rendre à fort de
france aux antilles cyril gautier le
directeur éditorial de france antilles
notre partenaire à une question à vous
poser il est depuis fort de france on
écoute
bonjour christian cambon vous présidez
la commission des affaires étrangères de
la défense à ce titre comment voyez-vous
les outre-mer français prendre une place
sur la nouvelle carte géopolitique qui
se dessine à la vue du conflit actuel en
ukraine
les outre-mer ont une importance tout à
fait particulière parce que non
seulement ce sont des des lieux de de
présence française présence culturelle
présence économique présence militaire
bien évidemment aux antilles nous avons
un rôle tout à fait particulier est
prégnant nous avons des forces de
souveraineté qui assure non seulement la
sécurité du territoire mais aussi cette
présence française la lutte contre tous
les trafics et de celle ci en provenance
d'amérique latine un certain nombre de
nos îles des antilles peuvent être
touchées mais je pourrais en dire tout
autant de la nouvelle calédonie de la
réunion avec je le rappelle la plus
grande zone économique exclusive ce qui
fait de nous un partenaire sur les cinq
continents grâce à cette présence est
donc il faut que la france renforce ses
moyens notamment ses moyens de défense
et moyens militaires sur les territoires
et départements d'outre-mer des maîtres
korkmaz tv5 on va rester alors dans ce
dans cette zone géographique vous avez
fait une visite il y a quelques mois à
taïwan vous avez rencontré pas moi pas
moi il y avait une rencontre sénatoriale
s'est déroulé qu'est ce que vous pensez
de cette chine qui ce qui est un pas en
embuscade durant cette guerre en ukraine
et qu'ils regardent très attentivement
le déroule le déroulé diplomatique alors
j'ai des nouvelles fraîches parce que
hier j'ai passé plus de deux heures avec
l'envoyé spécial du président xi jinping
qui est venu
me rendre visite au sénat est gelée
accueillis au nom du président larcher
et donc j'ai évidemment interrogé ce
haut personnage sur l'attitude de la
chine notamment par rapport à la russie
et à l'ukraine donc j'ai eu droit un
langage particulièrement bien à cabrer
sur le fait que la chine se prononcer
pour l'intégrité et la souveraineté des
territoires pour le respect de la charte
des nations unies pas tous ces langages
que je connais bien et donc ce que moi
j'ai demandé à notre à cet envoyé est
bien c'est que la chine joue tout son
rôle notamment vis-à-vis de monsieur
poutine pour faire arrêter ce conflit
effroyable qu'elle joue son rôle et les
membres du conseil de sécurité et je
pense effectivement que il ya parfois
une différence entre les paroles et les
actes parce qu'on voit bien que la chine
n'est pas parfaitement hostiles à la
politique de monsieur poutine dans la
région est-ce que vous pensez que les
taïwanais ont raison de craindre d'être
de devenir l'ukraine de la chine est ce
que c'est un scénario qui vous fait peur
je pense que ce qui vient de se passer à
la faveur à la faveur si j'ose dire du
drame une craignant renseigne les
chinois c'est à dire que les chinois
comme les russes pensaient que
l'occident à la suite de la sphère
syrienne et de bien d'autres laisserait
une fois de plus passé et que l'on
pouvait avancer ce sont des pays pour
lesquels la force c'est une règle
importante donc peut-être penser ton
jeudi peut-être penser donc si on a vu
ce qui s'est passé sur hong kong où il
ya eu des protestations puis finalement
hong kong a disparu de l'actualité et
hong kong maintenant et quand même
fortement contrôlé par la chine je pense
que
là le fait que l'europe soit peut-être
plus forte et plus unie au lendemain de
l'affairé ukrainienne peut avoir une
incidence sur la chine parce que la
chine n'oublie pas que l'europe c'est un
marché de 500 millions de consommateurs
alors on parle d'une europe forte u10
pas complètement puisque il ya eu un
accord trouvé sur le sur l'embargo sur
le pétrole non un accord qui a été
trouvé au prix d'une d'un d'un compromis
sur sur le sur le pétrole acheminé vers
la hongrie la moldavie et la république
tchèque est ce que c'est un premier pas
vers cette europe à la carte où
effectivement tout le monde ne serait
pas aligné sur la même politique et il
faut bien comprendre aussi la situation
géographique des pays que vous venez
d'évoquer notamment la hongrie ils n'ont
tox aucun accès à la mer donc si vous
voulez il faut bien qu'ils trouvent une
source d'énergie donc je pense que le
rôle de l'europe c'est d'aider ces pays
à prendre de la distance à se séparer de
ses approvisionnements russes et ça peut
prendre un tout petit peu de temps c'est
quand même pas une affaire qui va se
régler sur un claquement de doigts je
pense que c'est verbal or balle pardon a
opposé un veto ainsi oui cette exception
n'avait pas été fait vis-à-vis de son
connais bien le comportement de victor
van qui pour défendre les intérêts de la
hongrie et parfois pose parfois des
actes
assez autoritaire mais la revendication
de ces pays
elle est légitime elle est légitime au
sens où au sens où il faut les aider à
s'approvisionner de manière autonome en
dehors des circuits russe est-ce que du
coup vous êtes favorable à la fin de la
règle de l'unanimité ce qui pourrait
régler aussi c'est un problème de je
pense qu'à terme si l'europe s'élargit à
tous ces pays d'europe centrale des
balkans qui sont à la porte et qu'il
frappe moi je reçois régulièrement les
mises affaires étrangères de ces pays
qui viennent nous dire je passe je pense
au monténégro je pense à la macédoine du
nord etc quand sommes-nous quand
allons-nous être reconnu comme partie
intégrante de l'europe je pense qu'à ce
moment là la règle de l'unanimité et
restera intenable au président de la
république que de prendre les
initiatives au sein du conseil des chefs
d'état des réformes nécessaires mais
elles sont inéluctables à mon sens dans
les années qui viennent alors dans
l'actualité christian cambon les
incidents au stade de france bien sûr où
des supporteurs anglais et espagnols
aussi un la presse espagnole est très
sévère depuis hier donc ont été malmenés
auditions de gérald darmanin mise de
l'intérieur hier chez vous au scénar à
17 heures est ce qu'un impact
diplomatique fort est ce que vous
craignez que l'image de la france très
affecté je rappelle qu'on est à deux ans
d djo et que l'été prochain en fin d'été
prochain c'est la coupe du monde de
rugby c'est la dimension qui
m'interpelle un peu puisque je suis en
charge des relations internationales du
sénat sous l'autorité du président c'est
l'image que cela donne je voyais moi
aussi ce matin des réactions très dures
de la part de la presse anglaise qui
rayonne et espagnol bon alors il ya eu
des explications j'allais dire un peu
embarrassé
de la part de gérard darmanin bon les et
les renseignements que nous avons moi je
suis pas totalement experts sur cette
affaire mais les renseignements que nous
avons montrent qu'il ya eu effectivement
peut-être un affolement au sein des
forces de l'ordre qui ont vu cette masse
de gens arrivent et je rentre pas dans
la polémique savoir si c'était des faux
vrais billets ou des vrais faux billets
mais je pense qu'il ya eu en tous les
cas pas mal aussi de voyous qui sont en
profiter on est très habitués
souvenez-vous des manifestations du 1er
mai etc et des groupes qui sont très
organisés pour mettre le bazar c'est
très inquiétant effectivement pour
l'image de la france avait eu la peau du
rugby et des jeux olympiques et des jeux
olympiques parce que quand même la
france c'est une date qui approche et je
pense que cet événement aura de bons
qu'il va faire réfléchir en profondeur
la manière d'organiser la sécurité les
joueurs la sécurité des spectateurs dans
une manifestation qui risque
d'accueillir plusieurs millions durant
votre vie sur gérald darmanin de vos
anciens collègues il était le rappelle
le membre des républicains écoutez il
n'a pas la meilleure folates fonction la
plus facile moi je
je lui reconnais le mérite de se battre
pour le maintien de l'ordre il peut
commettre où il peut laisser commettre
des erreurs c'est tout à fait possible à
lui d'en tirer les conséquences mais moi
je les ai vus notamment sur la sécurité
dans mon département du val de marne je
les ai vus annoncé des rénovations de
commissariats des renforcements donc
j'ai plutôt un a priori positif mais
c'est évidemment dans les actes qu'il
faut le voir et on voit bien qu'en
france il ya quand même un problème
d'insécurité qui touche encore toutes
sortes de département les milieux
urbains les milieux euro et donc il faut
accélérer cette ses efforts un mot sur
le parti à public puisqu'on en parle les
républicains au sénat c'est le dernier
bastion des républicains je rappelle le
score valley pécresse 4,7 pour cent aux
élections présidentielles comment vous
voyez l'avenir de ce parti vous en êtes
membre est ce que vous vous inquiétez
cette formation politique est elle en
totale déroute christian cambon écoutez
je suis bien évidemment assez triste du
résultat que l'on a fait et je pense que
le temps des explications n'est pas
encore venu pour une raison bien simple
c'est qu'actuellement à l'heure où on
parle moi j'ai tout un tas d'amis qui
sont en course pour les élections
législatives je pense qu'il va y avoir
des surprises des bonnes surprises car
chez les répudier les députés
républicains c'est le cas dans mon
département et bien il y à un
enracinement qui risque de faire la
différence c'est que michel herbillon va
repasser
initialement je pense mais je le
souhaite et je fais tout pour parce que
il est confronté à madame barbe on
essaie le député 1 voilà et madame argon
et totalement parachuté du reste est
d'abord elle était sortie du
gouvernement du diamant elle ne vote
même pas dans la circonscription pour
laquelle elle prétend est élu et c'est
le cas aussi de l'ancienne ministre des
sports chez mon ami jean brun à l'haÿ
les roses donc moi je trouve que c'est
globalement on sait qu'à une
implantation locale oui
ça va suffire à une dit non non on
n'avait plus de chef vous avez nicolas
sarkozy qui a clairement pas pris
position c'est à dire clairement pas
pris position pour valérie pécresse
pécresse c'est quand même un énorme
problème qu'est ce que vous pensez de
l'attitude de nicolas sarkozy vous
je ne l'approuvent pas je n'approuve pas
je ne l'approuvent pas parce que je
pense que président sarkozy aurait pu
même de manière laconique mais apporter
son soutien ce qui lui aurait du reste
rendu au lendemain de la défaite peut
être un rôle plus conséquent que celui
qu'ils tenaient à voir je n'en sais rien
il faut lui demander mais je sens en
revanche le vrai désarroi des militants
qui est à ce titre alors son leader pour
l'instant gênés à répondre est ce que
c'est un problème pour un grand parti
qui souillaient bien sûr gouvernement
bien sûr parce que dans chaque partie il
faut une incarnation et on voit bien les
partis qui n'ont plus de qu'elles ont
plus de chefs on voit du raid dans la
campagne bon et macro nistos mâcon
il ya madame le pen il ya des images qui
s'affiche et puis chez nous c'est un
petit peu plus court et nous on est
plutôt sur l'enracinement local mais je
pense que au profond au plus profond
d'eux les difficultés que nous
connaissons d'autres d'autres visages
vont sortir je pense qu'il est très
important de conserver au parlement une
opposition de la droite et du centre
républicaine car la famille politique
les idées politiques demeurent moi j'ai
rencontré beaucoup de gens qui disent on
a voté pour monsieur macron parce que
c'était utile ou n'a voté pour monsieur
zemmour parce que et parce que tout un
tas d'arguments votre candidate nous
plaisait pas etc mais je pense que cette
famille peut rendre revenir à l'origine
et on va le retrouver dans les résultats
des législatives jans vous voulez peser
là dessus vous vous sentez un baron des
républicains au roi du tout pas du tout
moi je suis
j'ai exercé les responsabilités j'étais
président de la formation dans le
département non non moi je me concentre
sur la défense les affaires étrangères
croyez-moi ça suffit je travaille 12
heures par jour et parfois même le
samedi le dimanche et ça suffit
largement à occuper ma vie
christian cambon merci d'avoir été notre
invité en direct ce matin d'en face aux
territoires vous êtes le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées du sénat et
sénateur du val de marne merci
infiniment merci à thierry barbeau dette
qui coproduit cette émission à vanessa
chaîne irina qui ont assuré la
coordination pascal quentin à la
production à nicolas renard qui dirige
la production de cette chaîne est à
véronique roosens vague qu'il a réalisés
au revoir à tous à jeudi prochain pour
face aux territoires merci
[Musique]